we have another story here which is I
think uh telling of some of the victory
of Republican strategy and getting the
left to change course on their values
which is also always a fun thing to see
them forced into as Asylum seekers in
City's care tops 54 800. mayor Adam
announces new policy to help Asylum
Seekers move from shelters now this is
the way the media frames this when you
are on this side yeah exactly and they
want to protect you if it was a
republican doing this in a red State the
story would be about how he was a
horrible man who's forcing families out
onto the streets New York city mayor
Eric Adams and uh today announced
additional policies to help Asylum
seekers in the city's care move out of
shelter and create critically needed
space for arriving families with
children seeking Asylum the city has
made every effort to continue serving
the more than 90 000 Asylum Seekers who
have arrived in New York City since last
spring but with an average of 3 100 to
500 people still arriving each day and
more than 54 000 migrants still in the
city's Care New York City is that
capacity having responded in the absence
of state or federal action so uh y'all
probably know at this point that another
part of Republican strategy recently
which has actually been very effective
is Ben Greg Abbott bussing
migrants up to these blue States and
what the blue states are saying is this
is cruel this is horrible you can't use
people as pawns and we don't have the
resources to sustain them yes I agree
with all of those things let's stop
allowing that to happen at the southern
border as well of course as soon as they
have to see The Economic Consequences
then it becomes a serious issue I love
when they admit that there's just not
room or resources for everyone in the
world who wants to come here this is New
York City this is an incredibly wealthy
part of the country everyone's trying to
leave these are the only people who seem
to want to move to New York right now
and New York is saying no go away we
can't take care of you well if New York
can't afford to take care of these
people what about the impoverished
border towns that are forced to what do
you guys think about this story well
it's a great example of making them live
out their their values and when your
values all are welcome and we will
accept we're a sanctuary City it is just
a matter of of numbers right the the
productive members of society produce
the tax revenue and then the
government's bends it and when that
becomes out of balance and is becoming
out of balance when you look at the
Exodus and I'm oh yeah you know my whole
family is still in New York City I'm a
proud New Yorker although I Live Now in
a farm and rural Virginia as you all
know and I talk about all the time but I
mean New York City will always be home
and we're 8th generation Seventh
Generation New Yorker but but but the
when you look at the Exodus of people
who are leaving like myself
um it's the it's the The Producers it's
the people and that people are you know
they're trying to blame climate change
but they're going to Florida in Texas
please tell me please tell me how
they're doing it
that was an article today I have to find
another article today about how climate
change is driving a lot of the migration
of of communities but they're all moving
to Arizona Texas and Florida and you're
like well well maybe they want more heat
I guess so it's kind of comical that
that's the accusation they're making but
the value the The Producers not the
sound ironian but the the people who
produce value who produce in society
Society are the ones leaving and the
people who take as crass as that sounds
migrants who come here with nothing all
they can do for a while is take they
need homes they need shelter they need
food they need health care when that
equation falls out of balance you have
mayor Adams who ran his whole campaign
about how he was a welcoming mayor all
are welcome all are welcome it's a
numbers game
Ayan Rand put it the coldest maybe but
but it is a numbers game and New York is
suffering that numbers game yeah well I
mean this is part of why what you just
explained a moment ago about the fact
that when people first come to the
country generally they are going to be
taking more than they're able to give
this is why we had a system in place why
we do have a system and why we're
supposed to adhere to the system of
sponsor families bringing people in and
then that family can help that person
while they're in the country it's not
all being paid for by taxpayers then
that person actually has an incentive to
get out on their feet because you don't
want to be an adult or a person with a
family living under someone else's roof
not contributing and not being able to
get out of that situation because you
haven't found a job like there's a
structure in place to create the proper
incentives for people who come here to
start producing as soon as possible but
in the United States there are two
fundamental positions when it comes to
Integra immigration there's the position
that we should have laws in the position
that laws are mean and those are
literally the only two positions by the
way within position one that we should
have laws there's a wide variety of
different positions people have on what
those laws should be but the dominant
view is it is mean to enforce those laws
how dare you suggest that they be
respected yeah it comes down to emotions
and rationale yeah for sure
unfortunately I think why I have a
family friend who's a Greek descendant
and tells the story about how Greek
communities used to send someone over
and they would someone it started with
someone opening a retail business like
it was a grocery store candy store or
something and um eventually they were
able to then bring over someone else
from the small town in Greece where they
were from and eventually that person was
able to move farther out and start start
a store and there there was a community
support element so much so that she
still attends uh a big family gathering
now they're not all related but it's
just sort of this community event of
people who are descended from literally
one town in Greece that's so cool to me
and I find it interesting that we had
systems that believed in support and
mutual benefit and instead our
immigration policy has gotten so
deranged that we are saying you should
only go across the border because Eric
Adams will say yes I will help you so
you will elect me and I will look good
but actually when it comes time when
push comes to shove he is now saying uh
so suburbs of New York Orange County you
guys need to house single migrant men in
your hotels and if you don't do so
you're the bad guys how are you not
doing this problem I invited people up
here I don't think I can handle anymore
so now it's your job to start cleaning
up because New York dominates the same
city during a party at someone else's
house and then leaving yeah yes or like
being like yeah I have too many people
coming to visit me so you they all are
gonna stay in your houses around me
because I said so well at least if you
invite me to your house I'm probably
going to bring a bottle of wine yeah you
know but but sometimes our our the folks
that were inviting to this this country
bring nothing right but then or they
want legal substances like fentanyl or
aren't invited
I have a pretty radical and
environmental position and I am a no
immigrant position right I am I am not
pro-immigration people say well we need
immigrants they diversity is our
strength I love that and shouldn't be
New York want as many of them like why
can we not be closed why why do we need
so any immigrants in the people tell me
that they provide this in tremendous
value I see them undercut wages I see
them as a drain on social systems which
I also oppose I am I am a no immigration
I always say I'm elected president there
will be no immigration for like my
Administration yeah the president after
me can change that but we're going to go
four straight years with no immigration
I think an immigration moratorium is a
completely valid option because we are
not just like struggling with this we
are really in crisis and that is not
okay I think this is I mean I've said it
before I think the open border puts the
men and women and children who are
trafficked across In Harm's Way it hurts
the Border communities it hurts our
country overall I think it hurts people
who try to apply legally to come here
because I think ultimately we do a
disservice by allowing immigration I
would be for an immigration moratorium
uh but I can understand when if you
don't really read about anything and if
you're not super political you're not
really into news and you just hear sob
story after sob story about how actually
the people who say this stuff are racist
and actually they they are harmful to
everyone you know I could understand
where you would be misled and probably
from a very sweet nice place of
compassion it's just not accurate I'm
also married to an immigrant I have to
make that clear
well I I want to mention Australian if
that counts but I mean they're kind of
American as far as a moratorium goes I I
just like it's not one of those things
where I go oh that's bad that's racist I
just haven't seen the numbers to know
whether that's necessary no I think I
think if we I think if a moratorium
becomes necessary absolutely I don't
know the stats I do know that we have
had an unprecedented and unsustainable
number of people pouring across the
border I think in an ideal situation a
country should be able to welcome
immigrants who are coming to try to make
a better life for themselves right but
it's important for political leaders to
do the hard work of maintaining the
standard of living for the citizens who
were born there and who live there and
not just allow anyone into the country
when that is going to come at a
tremendous burden for the population of
that country there's a hospital near
Dulles Airport Port called I think it's
Stone Springs that friends of mine who
live in that area used to tell me they
have a sign outside for the ER five
minute wait four minute wait
um but now we we we train or we fly uh
multiple flights per day of illegals and
we drop them off and the first thing
they do is they go to the airport and
now the local community says the ER or
the local hospital excuse me thank you
and now the local community says well
now the ER has a 15 18 20 25 and they're
like what what's going on what well
that's the result of unchecked
immigration so exactly you don't have
diverticulitis or a heart attack because
your services are now severely
encumbered well it's a reality that's
not bad or good it's well it's bad but
it's reality well okay and so it's this
there was one time I think where you
could have the left if they were
remotely consistent or cared about the
things they claim to care about you
could even have the left making an
argument for a moratorium and that was
during coven people weren't allowed to
go to work people weren't able to visit
their loved ones in the hospital while
they were dying people funerals of loved
ones because this disease was just too
dangerous and everyone was going to die
if it was allowed to spread but we were
just letting people into the country
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only show was
exclusive thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next time